[Arabic recitation]
salah.
The author
as we discussed yesterday
after
mentioning the narrations
and evidences for the position of salah
and the very very serious
seriously lofty and high
place and status salah has from amongst
all of our other acts of worship. It's a
pillar of Islam. It's the second pillar
of Islam.
It is
something that is
very very important
and critical
to a person's relationship with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
being founded
at all
or at least being founded on anything
that is
solid or would be considered solid
grounding.
He then mentions
narrations of the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam from Bukhari and Muslim
and some from elsewhere
regarding the dangers
of abandoning salah.
The dangers of
not
making the prayers that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala has commanded
or not making them on time or not making
them correctly.
[Silence]
He narrates to us that the messenger of
Allah salallahu alaihi wasallam said,
and this narration is in Sahih Muslim,
he says, "Between what stands between a
man
and shirk
and disbelief, kufr,
is abandoning salah.
And this is very serious.
What stands between a man
and ash-shirk wal-kufr
tark as-salah. Now,
notice the wording here.
He doesn't say
[Arabic recitation]
Qala
wal-kufr
tark as-salah.
There's a big difference there.
He says, "What stands between a man
and
polytheism, shirk,
and disbelief itself
is abandoning salah."
Meaning once a person abandons salah,
nothing stands between these two.
This narration is in Sahih Muslim. Qala
[Arabic recitation]
qala sami'tu Rasul Allah sallallahu
as-salah
faman tarakaha
faqad kafar.
This narration is in a Sunan, Sunan ibn
Majah,
Sunan an-Nasa'i, Sunan at-Tirmidhi.
On the authority of Buraydah
ibn al-Husayb radiyallahu 'anhu, he
says, "I heard the Messenger of Allah
[Arabic recitation]
'The true
difference between us
and them is salah.
And so whoever abandons it
has
fallen into disbelief. This narration is
in a sunan.
This
and other narrations it,
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
warns of the dangers of abandoning
salah.
It's not an issue of mere disobedience.
It's an issue of a person's Islam. His
very soul hangs in the balance
because of his salah. And why is that?
If we look at the nature of abandoning
salah,
when we look at the nature of abandoning
salah completely,
not not praying at all,
we see that
it is very different than just a than
abandoning zakah,
or fasting, or even hajj,
from the other pillars of Islam.
Because of its frequency,
it's frequency.
If you imagine a person that does not
pay zakah,
how often does that occur? At most once
a year. It can't happen more than that,
right? Or once a harvest.
A person who abandons fasting
is at most once a year, 1 month out of
the year.
A person who abandons hajj,
this is
one time out of a person's lifetime.
But a person who abandons salah,
constantly making the same choice
consciously five times every single day.
This intensifies the level of
disobedience because of its consistency,
because of the
stubbornness of a person upon this.
Another
issue that sets salah aside from all
other
issues or all other types of worship
is when we look at
what salah is.
What it is.
Salah
has been made
so accessible
that no matter where person is, no
matter what a person's situation is,
salah is accessible and the and the
conditions of salah and prerequisites
are equally as accessible.
First of all,
all of the earth has been made a place
of salah
and a purifying and pure place to pray.
Even if a person doesn't have water to
prepare, they make the ablution.
Another thing is that
salah has many allowances.
When a person has the time to make salah
from the start of the war till the sun
sets, the entire day starting from
afternoon
all the way until the sun sets, this is
a person's time to make this prayer.
When we look at the length of salah, we
see that it is very brief.
And then when we look at the makeup of
salah,
salah has in it
the essence of all worship of Allah.
Salah has in it the essence of all
worship of Allah
and especially the five pillars of
Islam.
So when we look at salah, it has
elements of zakat in it and sadaqa.
Because a person
sets that time aside to pray, they are
unable to
you know, they're unable to deal or
unable to work during those moments.
And so, there is a level of sacrifice
there. It has elements of fasting in it.
Because a person cannot eat or drink
anything while they are in salah.
It has elements of hajj and umrah in it
because a person faces towards Mecca.
Faces towards the Masjid al-Haram.
[Arabic recitation]
some places, a person outright says it.
Right? Outright repeats it.
Likewise,
salah
is a repeating thing every single day
and night. Don't think of it usually
because of
we were born into a world that has
watches and clocks. Right? So, we think
of the day as 24 hours usually cuz it's
how it's divided. But,
it's really when we look at the division
of salah, we have night time, we have
day time, and we have break of dawn.
So, it is three sections.
We have the break of dawn.
We have day time prayer, which is Dhuhr
until
Maghrib. And then we have night time
prayer, which is Maghrib all the way
until
and Isha all the way until the break
of dawn again, Fajr.
So, when a person insists upon
abandoning salah,
they are disobeying Allah in day and in
night.
In day and in night.
So, because of these reasons that I've
just mentioned many others,
we see that
the prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
has said what he said.
Why did he say these things?
Because
why is it so serious that if a person
leaves salah,
the integrity of their deen is in
question,
is because of the intensity
of the disobedience,
and it speaks volumes to the integrity
of a person's religion.
Right?
Even if it's existence becomes
questionable.
Nasa'alullah subhanahu wa ta'ala an
[Arabic recitation]
yutuna zakah. Nas'aluhu subhanahu wa
ta'ala an yaj'alana mimman yastami'una
al-qawla fayattabi'una ahsanah.
[Arabic recitation]